we're now going to look at
two very famous and very widespread
widely used examples of affine functions
one is from differential calculus it's
just the taylor approximation
so that goes back a couple hundred years
and the second one is a regression model
from statistics
we'll start with the taylor
approximation
so in the taylor approximation suppose
you have a function
that uh the way you'd say this is you
maps
rn to r now rn is the set of all
n vectors so the way you should read
this
notation which is universally uh it's
you know it's a universal mathematics uh
notation is this says that f is a
function
and it takes as an argument or input or
however you like to think of it
um a vector an n vector so n n real
numbers
and then it returns or evaluates to or
gives
a single number r uh back as the result
that's that's what the second term
means so for example you might write f
of
u or something like that and that would
be u here
must be an n vector and f of u is is a
real number okay
um all right so the taylor approximation
is just this it's the first order taylor
approximation it says the following um
that and we're gonna develop this nero
point z
um and it's this so it's f hat um
and the idea of a hat uh is that's
common uh
mathematical notation that hints that
it's an approximation so when you see f
hat it's an approximation
of f um and that's a cro that that that
notation
or it's just a convention that's common
across many many areas of applied
mathematics
uh it's not universal i mean there's
other subfields where hat means
something different like you know
fourier transform or something
but it's just something to understand is
that very commonly a hat means an
approximation
okay so this says f hat of x that's my
that's my approximation of f and it's
going to be the following function
it's f of z now that's a constant it's
just whatever number that is
minus 2 plus and then what we have is a
sum of terms each one can be interpreted
as the approximate change in f
due to the change in that component of x
or z so here for example x1 minus z1 is
the amount you have changed the first
component from z1
to x1 and then you multiply that by this
partial derivative the partial
derivative
of f with respect to x one evaluated at
z and so
you add up all these sort of correction
terms and you get this function and
that's f hat now
that function is affine we'll we'll see
that momentarily but the
main property of the taylor expansion is
this is that f
hat uh this approximation is very close
to f of x
when the x's are all near the z's
and a picture will will explain that but
very close means not just
they're close but they're very close
right
okay now we can write out
uh this taylor approximation using
vector notation and inner
product and that looks like this so this
says that f hat of x
is equal to f of z that's a number plus
and then up here if you look at this
term you will recognize it is a sum
of products of two things and if we
collect those two things into two
vectors
one is just the vector x minus z and the
other one
is a vector whose components are these
partial derivatives and that's got a
name
so that that's called the gradient
vector
and so the gradient vector is the set of
all partial derivatives of a scalar
value
function with respect to x1 x2 x3 up to
xn
and so and this we recognize up here
it's just an inner product and so
we've got this beautiful compact formula
that looks like looks like that
um and it's you know it's kind of nice
because it looks like the formula you
would have uh
if x and z were scalars and here this
would just be simply
f prime of z which is in fact the
gradient when
you have just one variable okay now to
see that this is an affine function we
could write it a different way
we could write it as uh the gradient
of f uh inner product uh with
x sorry that's at z inner product with x
and this you can think of this as your a
if you like
in in the affine model and then plus and
then the offset
and the offset is going to be f of z
minus the gradient of f at z
inner product with z okay
and so this part here we would call
b and what that says is that f hat of x
has the form
uh inner product of a and x uh
plus b so okay so this is uh so
the summary of all this is in fact you
can even think of
you know a a good fraction of
derivative calculus is in fact simply
it's an
organized method for making affine
approximations of functions so let's see
a quick picture now the picture
i'm drawing is uh z and x are
scalars so that's so i can draw it but
i'll say a little bit about how this
works in the higher dimensional case so
here it is
so here's here's the curve which is f of
x so we can see f of x here
um and uh here's a point z
and then this red dashed line is the
graph
of f hat of x and you can see it's a
line so it's it's an affine function
um and so what i meant to say earlier
when i said it was very close when
you're close is if you were to imagine
zooming in there what you would see is
that if you moved
a little bit from x like i'll just make
up on like 0.01
then what would happen is the
approximation would be very accurate
like way better than 0.01 like .01
squared
right which is 10 to the minus 4. so
that that's what this means so it's
tangent uh to the curve at that point so
this is
uh and this you know from calculus okay
now in higher dimensions
uh for example in two what we would do
to visualize this is we would imagine
let's say a plane and then a surface
above it and that surface would be f
i pick a point z i go up to the surface
and then what i would i would have is my
graph
would be a plane and it will be the
tangent plane it's the
it's the plane that just sort of touches
the
graph at that point and is uh actually
parallel to it right at that point and
that would be that would be the first
order taylor
approximation of the function okay
so this is one area of it's an organized
method
for producing affine approximations of
non-affine functions
okay our next example is
the regression model this is
this is essentially a human-made uh
thing because these are just these are
just approximate models but it's
absolutely ubiquitous
you may have already heard about this in
other courses i guarantee you you will
take
hear about it in other courses um if
that's not the case then well you're not
taking the right courses but
let's do so it's a very important thing
to understand it's it's not complicated
but it's it's super important and we're
going to see it a whole lot later
much more later in this class okay so a
regression model
is this and the idea is i have a
a vector x and i think of x as a feature
vector
so it's its components are various
numbers
associated with an item right could be a
patient admitted to the
uh emergency room or something like that
um
it could be uh it could be
a certain uh each item could correspond
to a
company on a publicly traded exchange or
something
like that and then the entries of x are
attributes
of that item so for example if it's a
patient
you could encode are they it could be
their height their weight we could
encode their sex with
you know zero and one for let's say male
and female
we could uh we could say are they are
they experiencing chest pain that could
be encoded as uh
zero or one and so on so that would be
uh
these would be attributes of the item
right for
a company it could be the total
capitalization of the company
the last year's return uh it could be
just various
it could be the sector that the company
operates in or something like that so
okay so this would be these would be
attributes of it
and then y is something that we want to
predict right and
what why could be for example the number
of days
that patient will ultimately stay in the
hospital right of course we don't know
it because
who knows we have to see how they do and
all that kind of stuff
so but that's why um oh well we know it
after they've left the hospital
and let's say for a company it could be
what is going to be the return
on their stock over the next quarter is
it going to go up
5 down 10 percent i don't know that's
what
that's we would call that y okay and
so we would have what we have is a
a model or regression model it's like a
prediction model and here's what it is
it's actually relatively straightforward
we're going to look at it
um why the prediction is
an offset v that's called the offset uh
plus
and then an inner product of the feature
vector
with a weight vector uh or coefficient
vector beta
um and i'm using some i'm using some of
the tradition some of the traditional
notation
that you'd see in a regression model um
so this is this is the model
and of course you know we could write
this out and it's worth it's very
important to write it out so that's like
beta 1
x 1 right all the way up to
beta and x n plus v and we can interpret
all sorts of things they're super cool
like if all the features are zero
our prediction is v so that's what v
is um oh and i should say here that y
hat
is an approximation so must be an
approximation or prediction
of what y is right so y is the true
outcome or something like that
so this is useful in cases where you can
see
x you don't know why because maybe it
hasn't happened yet or something because
it's something in the future
it's how many days will they stay in the
hospital or what will your return be
over the next month
so you don't know it but you do know x
and so this gives you
a way to make a prediction of what
that's going to be
okay so it's a prediction model all
right um
and we can interpret everything very
nicely here right so for example
beta1 is the amount by which your
prediction
goes up when x1 goes up by one
okay so that's that's kind of the idea
so and we'll we'll see that in a very
specific example i'm going to show you
in a minute
so that's the idea um if if a beta is
for example
uh negative that means that when that
feature goes up your prediction goes
down
okay so uh for example
uh a feature could be we
here's a feature ready it's x7 and it
says is this a person a
heavy smoker z is one zero means not a
heavy smoker
and if y is if we're trying to predict
let's say
lifespan then i would i would hope that
beta
7 is negative and what that means is
that anyway a good model would have beta
7 negative
and that means that if you're a heavy
smoker it our prediction of your
lifetime is going to go down
in fact quite literally beta 7
which is negative is going to be the
number of years
we our model predicts you will lose in
your lifespan if you're a heavy smoker
okay so we'll come back we're gonna
we're gonna be talking about this in
great detail later this is just your
first introduction
but the main point is this that that is
an affine function of the features
that's it it's it's linear plus a
constant okay
so that's that's that's the idea of of a
regression
model um i'll just give you a quick
example
and like i said we're going to come back
to this and look at this in much more
detail later
so here's an example just to sort of get
in your i had how this might work
so let's say why is the selling house
uh is the selling price of a house uh
that's it's how much it sells for
and let's say it's in thousands of
dollars so you know 230 means it sold
for 230
000 okay and that's in some location
over some time period right
and the regressor is going to be
extremely simple it's going to have
the feature vector is going to have just
two features right and it's going to be
um the house area is number one
and the house area we're going to give
them thousands in thousands of square
feet so a thousand square
hou the square foot house is is a one
and bedrooms
is going to be of course just the
integer so for example uh
you know 2.1 comma
uh three you know is a that's a 2100
square foot house with three bedrooms uh
just for example
okay now i should add this is an
embarrassingly simple example
uh no one would predict a house price
based on
two features right uh real ones like
zillow or trulia they would
they would actually uh predict a house
price based on
[Music]
tens or hundreds of features right so
but nevertheless it still
just gives you a rough idea of what it's
going to look like okay and so
here's a regression model uh right now i
i cannot tell you
where this regression model came from
but that's not the point right now just
to understand what it says
super interesting it says that beta is
148.73 and minus 18.85 i
and the offset is 54.4 okay now by the
way later in the class
in the course you will be able to fit
regression models
to data but for right now let's just
it's important understand just what is a
what a regression model is what does it
say
and it's actually really cool let's
let's talk about it for a second here
this first one we can interpret in a
beautiful way it says that
basically for every thousand square feet
of
increase in house size um our model
predicts that the selling price is going
to go up by about 150 000
okay so i mean you could even sort of
divide it and say well it's you know
whatever it is it's
1500 whatever dollars per square foot
however it works out right
something like that right um so
so that that's an interpretation there
um now this one
that's that's tricky to it looks strange
right it says
it says wait a minute this is weird this
says that when the number of bedrooms
goes up
we predict the house price to go down
okay so
um then you think that surely that's
wrong and you go
well it might not be wrong i'll give a
rough explanation for it now
this says that if the number of bedrooms
goes up but the house area stays the
same
then in fact the price our prediction of
the price goes down a little bit
you know and you could chalk this up or
if
someone asked you why you could say i
don't know maybe it's it's more crowded
or cramped right if you have a
1200 square foot house and i add another
bedroom yeah it's
it's too cramped or something like that
um i'm just making this up also
it's probably a good idea not to get too
i mean you can think about the model but
don't don't take it too seriously
okay so this is the uh the this would be
the idea oh
uh this offset um that's a 54.4 000.
you can give kind of an approx but an
approximate interpretation goes like
this
you would say that that's actually the
cost of the lot
because it's actually that is our
prediction of the selling price of a
house
whose vector is whose feature is zero
zero
but that's a house with zero foot square
footage
and um zero square footage and no
bedrooms right so in other words known
as not a house
so i mean i wouldn't take anything too
seriously but if you wanted to interpret
this
you could certainly interpret it that
way that that that's the price of the
land or the base price or something like
that
okay so that's a regression model um and
let's just look at a quick example of
how you might use that regression model
well
um i've shown you five pounds this is
five houses okay
um and actually the houses we selected
actually the first one has one bedroom
then two
three four and five house okay but
doesn't have to
um and then uh what i'm gonna give you
uh by the way this is
actually some real data it doesn't
matter but here the first one is 846
square feet
we can see that here uh here um the
this this five uh this five bedroom
house that's uh 39 that's almost 4 000
square feet
okay um and uh
so here what's listed here is what the
actual price
the house sold for okay and then over
here
that's our regression model prediction
now by the way
if we know how much the house sold for
you definitely do not need a regression
model because
if someone says what do you think it's
going to sell for you'd say it just sold
and then as a matter of fact it just
sold for 234.5 k
period right so you don't need a
prediction well you need the prediction
model
before that when you'd say hey how much
do you imagine
this house is going to sell for when it
does
and that's our prediction and you can
look at these two and you can just
eyeball them and
you know this kind of makes sense you
can see we're getting the flavor of it
right i mean we do predict that for
example that sells for a whole lot more
than that
um we make some good pretty good
predictions right like that's a that's a
pretty good one
that's not such a great one right there
uh that's that's not fantastic that's
you know okay
and that's not so great really that last
one uh that first one
um i mean this is silly because you know
uh
i'm you know we're attempting to i mean
it's not a it's not
unexpected we're attempting to predict
the price a house
sells for based on two attributes and
nothing else
that's ridiculous because in fact it's
going to depend on
at least 50 attributes like how good are
the schools in this neighborhood
how much of how other houses in the same
neighborhood sold for things like that
so there's a lot more going and at the
end of the day by the way what the house
price is
is it is it is precisely the amount
somebody somewhere decides to pay for it
and it obviously has much more to do
than even the 50 parameters
that let's say you know one of these
other
commercial uh house price
sale price guessing companies would
would use right it depends on
who who falls in love with the house uh
who
uh oh it's you know it's two blocks from
your cousin
uh or whatever or some good friends i
mean so there's lots of other things
that determine that
but the main idea here is it's just an
approximation and it's an affine
approximation
okay and here would be and we'll get to
this
uh later but i think this is a scatter
plot of maybe
five six hundred houses from a certain
area over a certain time period
and what we're plotting here is this
these are these are
sales that actually happen so in some
sense this axis
the um the x-axis that's real that's
like that's that's like it closed
we went to the county assessor's office
or whatever whatever it is and this is
you can get the official uh amount that
changed hands
to you know to buy the house right um on
this
axis what we're doing is we're gonna
we're gonna predict our regression model
now our regression model is pathetically
simple right it uses two regressors and
all sorts of other stuff um and
you know if our prediction model were
perfect everything would be on this
diagonal line
the x equals y line everything would be
there because it just means basically
that
our prediction and the actual price were
exactly consistent right so
um that's not the case but you can see
that you know a lot of them are they're
kind of concentrated
towards the line you can see a couple
things uh for example here's some
examples of
ones where we do it absolutely truly
terrible job
of predicting right so um i mean this
these are just terrible job this is this
is an example of that of something that
sold for
hundred thousand and our prediction was
like
three hundred i mean we were off by a
factor of two
right um on the other hand we have a
bunch of houses where we did
pretty well so anyway so this is just
your first uh exposure
to a regression model if you haven't
seen it in other classes
main takeaway here is it is an affine
function so it's an example of an affine
function
you